companies have become more and more
complicated people lose purpose they
lose meaning they lose directions they
have to do undo redo there is more and
more work on work more and more meetings
more and more reporting needs more and
more emails and less and less is
achieved so people have to work harder
and harder longer and longer creating
less and less value and this makes a
difference in their productivity and of
course in the satisfaction at work with
my teams we started to study what was
happening why people for example when
you were interviewing them to understand
their job because consulting is about
understanding what people do some of
them started to cry to cry so this was
not a firing interview it was not a
recruiting interview we are you tell
people sorry you will not make it and it
was just asking people tell me about
your work
what do you find the most interesting
the most difficult with whom do you need
to interact to accomplish your task how
do you see your future and in the middle
some people started to cry so this is
very surprising this use not to happen
10 years ago if you go back to Frederick
Taylor Frederick Taylor the father of
scientific management which is the
underpinning approach to the whole
toolbox used to say employees should
receive every day clear instructions and
they should execute these instructions
whether they are right or wrong so when
you say that you clearly say that you
don't want people to use their
intelligence their judgment execute
whether the instruction is right or
wrong Henry Ford used to say all I want
is a good pair of hands the problem is
that I need to take the person attached
to the hands clearly you didn't need
people's intelligence initiative
judgment because the business was much
simpler less complex today the business
has become much more complex so we need
to better leverage human intelligence
human judgment and this is not a matter
of boxes of scorecards of processes it
is how you make the tasks work together
so that people multiply because they
they cooperate multiply their
intelligence their energy making the
whole worth more than the sum of the
parts
[Music]